[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es ein
grundrezept von mir auf dass schon viele
von euch gewartet haben ich zeige euch
wie ich mein reis zubereiten
damit euch der reis auch genauso gut und
locker gelingt wie bei mir habe ich euch
die mengenangaben gramm genau in die
infobox geschrieben obwohl ich das ganze
ja immer mit tassen ab messe und hier
benötigen wir eine tasse reise ich nehme
am liebsten indischen was marty reis und
für eine tasse reis benötigen wir dann
ein dreiviertel tasten kochendes wasser
außerdem ein wenig öl butter etwas salz
und für die schöne farbe gemahlenen
curcuma bevor wir beginnen ist es ganz
wichtig die stärker aus dem reis zu
spüren und hierfür gebe ich den reis in
ein dünnes sieht und gebe darüber
fließendes wasser bei mir das wasser
jetzt galt es geht aber auch warm oder
laub warm und sobald ihr die stärke dann
ordentlich rausgespielt hat und das
wasser klar ist kann es auch schon
weiter gehen
nun geht es schon weiter auf dem herd
und hier gebe ich in meinen ausreichend
hohen topf mit öl und am besten nimmt
ihr da neutrales öl zum beispiel
sonnenblumen oder rapsöl
wer den nachgeschmack von olivenöl
besonders im reis mag der kann an der
stelle auch gerne olivenöl verwenden für
den anfang empfehle ich euch aber
definitiv neutrales öl
auf mittlerer stufe wird der reis jetzt
eine minute lang unter ständigem rühren
gedünstet und irgendwann merkt ihr dann
das euch ein lustiger geruch in die nase
steigt und dann ist es genau richtig
[Musik]
nachdem ihr das schön angedünstet habt
gebt ihr euer kochendes wasser hinein
und lässt es aber noch mal vollständig
aufkochen
[Musik]
vor dem aufkochen gibt ihr dann noch
salz und kurkuma mit hinzu kurkuma dient
hier nur der gelben farbe geschmack gibt
es nicht so viel ab aber ich sag ja das
auge isst mit und der gelbe reißt die
total köstlich aus
sobald die flüssigkeit dann einmal
auftaucht und sie muss auch wirklich nur
ganz kurz aufkochen und dann geht es
auch schon weiter schalten wir den herd
auf niedrige stufe meinem herz habe ich
neun stufen und nehme dann immer die
stufe 2 so funktioniert's am allerbesten
ganz ganz wichtig ist auch dass wir den
deckel drüber geben und ihr könnt
zwischendurch auch den deckel ruhig
abnehmen und mal schauen ob der durch
ist es macht gar nichts falls es noch
ein bisschen wasser unten am boden sein
sollte könnte den deckel auch einfach
wieder drauf geben
meistens dauert bei mir so ca 18 minuten
dann ist der reis auch schon durch und
ich gebe die butter mit hinzu die lasse
ich dann in der restwärme noch schmelzen
und gäbe noch mal kurz den deckel drüber
und sobald die mutter dann auch
geschmolzen ist vom menge ich das noch
mit dem durch gegarten reis und dann ist
auch schon fertig
[Musik]
dieser reise ist wirklich unglaublich
locker und der klebt nicht das ist mir
immer am aller wichtigsten so falls ihr
sehen heißt es auch mal nachmachen
möchte und sehen möchtet wie toll und
lecker das schmeckt dann schaut man
unten in die infobox ich habe euch
wirklich jeden gramm reingeschrieben
damit nichts schief geht
[Musik]
der reis schmeckt übrigens am nächsten
tag noch mindestens genauso lecker wie
am vortag weshalb ich meist auch schon
gleich die doppelte menge koche und
falls ihr euch den frack für wie viele
personen denn ein glas reis reicht das
sind zwei personen wenn sie ganz hungrig
sind oder drei mittel hungrige personen
es gibt ja immer noch eine hauptspeise
dabei
ich freue mich sehr auf euer feedback
wenn ihr meinen reis mal austestet
natürlich auch wie immer über fotos mit
dem hashtag s kitchen auf instagram
folgt mir dort unbedingt wenn ihr es
nicht schon tut und lasst mir auch gerne
hier ein abo damit ihr beim nächsten mal
auch wieder dabei sind und gerne
erinnere ich euch jetzt noch an meine
ramadan reihe dieses jahr in der es
jeden zweiten tag ein neues video gibt
jetzt wünsche ich euch viel spaß beim
kochen und sagt bis zum nächsten mal auf
dieses kitchen